welcome to salz talks money on
valuetainment economics i'm your host
adam sosnick and i'm here
to help you build your wealth and save
that money on today's episode it's all
about
investing that money let's talk money
all we talk is
all right so let me ask you when i bring
up the word the stock market
what comes to mind like what's going on
in your head right now i just brought up
the word the stock market
what's going through your head are you
seeing bulls you're saying bears you're
seeing ups you're seeing downs you're
seeing lefts and rights and greens and
reds
what's going on in your head right now
you're seeing the wolf of wall street
you've seen the trading room floors
what's going on in your head so let me
tell you something most people i ask
this question
see exactly that but here's the deal
that is not what investing is today
so in today's episode we're going to
break down three things what investing
was
what it is now and what you can do to be
a good
investor all right now let's get into
the stock market today now
pre pandemic the stock market was at all
time highs going great everything's
awesome next thing you know
covet happens plummeting the world's
ending the stock market's going crazy
sell sell sell now what's going on now
the stock market all of a sudden
four or five months later is exactly at
the same point it was
pre-covered or pretty close so what's
going on let's get into this all right
so
everyone thinks when the market's
plummeting the sky is falling south
south sell
we've learned some lessons y'all buy and
hold that's a strategy you need to be
paying attention to
so let before we get into what was going
on then and what's going on now
let's talk a couple different facts
about the stock market some numbers if
you will
so number one the stock market is the
greatest
wealth creator and money making machine
man has ever known so just if you did
not know that
now you know number two what is
investing
investing is pretty simple two
ingredients to investing you got time
and compound interest that's it time and
compound interest
equals investing number three let's get
into the numbers now we're talking
historical rate of returns historical
right
the stock market will return a 10 rate
of return
year over year over time that's not
accounting for inflation if you want to
account
for inflation which is a real thing
y'all the average roi
is seven and a half percent so
inflation's a real thing so that's the
historical rate of returns on the stock
market so here's the last thing you need
to know about the stock market the stock
market
is always going up
but sometimes it goes down you see what
i did there
it's always going up but sometimes it
goes down so what you have behind me is
a very
rudimentary stock market chart i tried
to draw it out i'm not an artist
please forgive me but let's just break
down what this means i just said that
the stock market is always going up
but sometimes it goes down so let's
break this down so if you look
year over year every year this is this
is the stock market for the last 100
years
1920 you can see right here to 2020 100
years we just talked about
that over the last 100 years the stock
market has returned between somewhere
between
seven and a half percent and ten percent
rate of return factoring inflation
so what does this chart actually
represent now if you draw the stock
market year to year it's kind of like
a crazy person it's going up it's going
down it's going left it's going right
it's up it's up is up
but take a look at this if you if i can
draw a line if you
weed out all the drama for your mama
right here
there's a line just consistently going
up
so let's take that into account the
stock market is always going up
but sometimes it's going down so
understand that the big picture it's
always
going up so now let's take it to the
tape so if you've seen my episodes
before i'm all about the tail of the
tape
where i break down two different options
of the same category so what we're going
to do now is this
we're going to break down what investing
was then back in the day we're talking
roughly 30 years ago versus today now
2020 and beyond so why did i pick
1990. i picked 1990 for a couple
different reasons so number one
for most of us who are millennials in
gen z we were young kids
or we weren't even born yet in 1990 we
were just kind of understanding what was
going on in the world
meanwhile the stock market was on fire
the 1980s were roaring
it just turned 1990 there was a stock
market crash in 1987.
now you got a floodgate of new people
entering the stock market it was
absolute pandemonium so enter the first
topic which is
perception versus reality when i asked
you the question in the beginning you
probably thought of the scenes that were
going on in the wall street movies
back in the day trading room floors high
action-packed dudes in suits on phones
going crazy buy sell left right oh my
god it's going crazy
that is not what investing is today
today's investing
is all about main street it's all about
main street all about you you're on main
street that's who i'm talking to
you could even be investing from your
home in your pajamas these days
on your computer not a big deal so back
in the day it was all about wall street
and chaos
today it's all about main street and you
as the individual investor
now moving on to the next topic let's
talk about the public
figures when it came to the stock market
so
back in the day who were the public
figures the public figures are all
freaking movie characters
you had this guy gordon gekko he was in
the movie wall street his
famous quote was greed is good greed is
right
greed works not so sure about that how
do you feel about greed is good
then you had these guys in the movie
boiler room you had vin diesel ben
affleck
and the famous quote from this boiler
room operation was
you think money can't buy you happiness
well look at the and smile on my face
they say money can't buy happiness look
at the smile on my face here to here
baby
those guys all ended up in jail and then
third and not least you have this guy
jordan belfort who is the wolf of wall
street we've all seen the movie
crazy guy like to party drugs chaos fun
it was all this legal
absolutely not we were making more money
than we knew what to do with
but let me tell you something about that
guy and all these guys actually
would i party with these guys sure would
i have a drink with these guys of course
would i travel and have a great time
with these guys
no problem would i invest my money with
these people
hell no you got to be out of your mind
so understand that investing
back in the day was exciting it was fun
it was completely chaos
[Music]
but that's not what investing is so now
let's get into the public figures today
the public figures today are all
investors and they're boring beautiful
billionaires who am i talking about here
so the poster child for investing today
is none other than the greatest investor
of all time
mr warren buffett mr warren buffett's
favorite quote is the best
investment that you can possibly make is
in what is in what
is in you yeah you and you're your own
biggest asset by far
what did he also say the next best
investment you can possibly make is
betting on the us economy since 19
whatever
the u.s economy has gone up up up up up
world wars
chaos 911 even with the coronavirus
or reaching all-time highs in the stock
market bet on yourself and don't bet
against america
the next public figure that i definitely
got to give a shout out to
is mr jack bogle jack bogle was the
founder of vanguard vanguard is the
largest
mutual fund company in the world all
right
rest in peace jack bogle he just died
not too long ago he was in his 90s but
what he did for the common investor
was astronomical he said enough of the
chaos enough of the wall street let's
keep it simple
let's keep it effective and let's even
the playing field
for all investors his most famous quote
was this
when i die and he just recently died
when i die my one wish is to keep my
reputation
intact think about that his one wish was
to keep his reputation intact
we're talking about him today as a
legendary investor meanwhile you get all
these other movie characters
who ended up in jail so those were the
public figures when it came to investing
now let's talk about strategy back in
the day it was all about
active trading what's active trading you
buy you sell you sell you buy you're
buying individual stocks you got hot
tips we're making moves or this or that
this is very complicated stuff where in
fact
only 20 percent of active traders
actually beat
the market so now let's talk about the
flip side today it's all about
passive investing now what's passive
investing you've heard this term before
you've heard of index investing you've
heard of simplified
investing well in fact eighty percent of
the time
just buying the market the s p 500 80
of the time you will beat the market so
what do i mean by this with strategy
sometimes less is more so if
active traders who are doing this day in
and day out
only beat the market 20 percent of the
time but passive investors would just
take the long term approach
keep it simple buy an s p 500 index fund
play the long game end up winning 80 of
the time
so understand that that's the 80 20 rule
with investing
now let's talk time frame back in the
day it was all about days
day trading active trading you're making
moves every single day
now with passive investing it's all
about
decades long-term approach days versus
decades
decades over days so here's the example
with this
it's not about timing the market trying
to time the market can't do that
it's about time in the market you
understand the difference
decades over days and time in the market
over
trying to time the market all right so
now here's a couple quick stats for you
when it comes to day trading now day
trading is very complicated
it's not easy it's very tough stuff
here's a couple quick facts for you
so over a year only five percent of day
traders are profitable five percent
and over the course of two years eighty
percent completely stop
trying to be a day trader so when you're
talking decades it's all about a long
term strategy you set it and forget it
and let your money ride
long-term moving right along now let's
get into the human
element back in the day you were
literally dealing with a human most of
the time and it was a stock broker he'd
be talking on his old school brick
phone the zack morris phone if you're
familiar with that and you'd be talking
to this guy who's a very personal
relationship but also a very emotional
relationship what do you think we should
do should we buy should we sell here's a
god i got a hot tip for you
should we do it should we not you should
invest understand something
with that relationship it's very
emotional and when it comes to investing
the last thing you need to be doing is
playing on your emotions
now it's all about robo advisors now
you're not even dealing with humans
anymore you're dealing with robots
you're dealing with tech
you're doing with digital you can buy
things at a click of a mouse you can
customize your portfolio it's very
simple it's very easy
and the fees are actually extremely low
now let's get into the feeds
so back in the day the fees were pretty
damn high and why why why were the fees
so high
because you had to go through a broker
there were no online exchanges you
couldn't just
get onto your computer and get onto a
discount broker online account but
you had to go through a broker the
broker would charge you every time you
made a move or every time you made a
trade a lot of times there was fifty
dollars a trade
or they would charge you one to two
percent aum which is
assets under management the fees were
very high now
the fee is much like flow right are they
low low low
we're getting low with the fees now why
are the fees so low well you got free
trades
you got discount brokerages so now you
got groups like vanguard fidelity
e-trade
robin hood betterment wealthfront and
acorns whose fees are very low the
average robo advisors fees are
point two percent now compare that to
what the fees are back in the day one to
two percent now you understand why these
stock brokers were rolling
in the dough i know it's very over
dramatized but this is why they were
doing
cocaine lunches and strippers in the in
the trading room floor it was a lot of
chaos a lot of fun
and it was all with your fees now the
only stripping that's going on today
are these stripped down fees of these
robo advisors you see what i did there
but understand this costs matter and you
keep them low low low
moving right along let's talk about
taxes everybody's favorite subject in
the world
is taxes right am i right no wrong but
we gotta address taxes
understand something that when it comes
to taxes back in the day
short term anything less than a year
that you're buying and trading less than
a year
is taxed at what ordinary income
which can be as high as 20 30 40 in some
cases
but if you buy and hold and you keep an
asset for
longer than a year here's the trick now
you're paying
capital gains tax which is basically
half the amount so maybe you're talking
10 15
so taxes do matter now understand that
these are things you can
control the fees you're paying and the
taxes that you're paying
are things that are within your control
understand that
moving right along let's talk about
retirement retirement back in the day
was all about having
a pension you work for a company for 40
years you retire you get a gold watch
they pay you until you're dead that's a
pension these days
do you have a pension comment below if
you've even heard about a pension
pensions barely exist anymore i think
less than five percent of the population
has a pension these days it's all about
that 401k
or that ira if you're not familiar with
these things
get yourself familiar with them all
right these are retirement plans that
you need to understand
let's talk about something else social
security
back in the day and our grandparents
today and our parents today they can
rely on social security
that's going to be there for them for us
you see a big question mark next to
social security what they're saying is
social security
will be there but maybe at half the
amount
that what people get today so the
average amount of social security today
is about 1800 bucks a month so that's
cut in half
talk about 900 bucks a month can you
survive on 900 bucks a month
i don't think so so understand that you
need to invest in your 401k
you need to invest in an ira and my
favorite thing that you can invest in is
called a roth
ira look them up these are helpful
helpful helpful retirement tools
for you to retire comfortably with last
but not least there's something called
target date funds if you're like dude i
don't even know about a 401k
i don't know about ira you can look into
something called a target date fund
which basically says i want to retire in
2050 and they'll just set you
up a plan with these robo advisors for
you to retire in 30 plus years
so it's a lot easier today but it's a
lot harder because there's no pension
and it's on you so now let's talk about
who's
winning from all this well back in the
day you know who was winning well big
corporate greed you're talking stock
brokers you're talking bankers you're
talking traders
it was the billionaire boys club who
benefited from all this now what do i
mean only 20
of us adults were investing in the stock
market in 1990
so now let's talk about today who's
winning today
well it's you the individual investor
yes you
you are able to capitalize on basically
what's happened in the stock market
today we're in fact now 55 of us adults
are investing in the stock market now if
you're not one of those 55 percent
well wake up y'all you got to get
involved in the stock market this is the
only way
for you to build wealth long term saving
is great
but investing is better so understand
what also was winning is equality and
fair ground is winning why is that
well 58 percent of men are investors but
not so bad
52 of women are investing so shout out
to the females out
there who are investing last but not
least you know who is also winning
the environment so now there's something
called sustainable investing where you
can invest in companies
that care about the environment check
that out so what's the big
payoff here now back in the day it was
all about the bling bling and
materialism we've all seen the corvettes
and the lamborghinis and the yachts and
the wolf of wall street and the party
and the excess
and the consumerism so what did that all
lead to well it led to a lot of debt so
what's my advice to you
stop buying things and start
buying experiences start buying
experiences things that you want to do
things that you're dying to do
places you want to go everything you
want to do that's all about experiences
that's all about financial freedom it's
not about buying things
it's about buying experiences these days
so that my friends was the tail of the
tape between investing then
versus investing now big difference as
you can see
so now my question for you is are you
ready to be an investor
i hope you answered yes now before i
started investing i
read this book called the boglehead's
guide to investing by none other than
jack bogle the founder of vanguard
who we mentioned earlier and they
basically started with this they were
basically like they kind of hyped it up
they were like are you ready to invest
are you ready to invest well before you
invest you need to do these three things
i was like oh damn i was ready to invest
what are these three things so
understand that you need to do these
three things
before you invest number one is you need
to have a game plan for your money
what does that mean you need to have a
budget a budget is a game plan for your
money
the most important part about a budget
is this it's understanding that it's all
about your net worth mentality
and not a paycheck mentality that's a
game plan for your money
number two he says the best investment
you can possibly make
is actually the opposite it's actually
paying off your debt
if you got high interest credit card
loans high interest auto loans loans as
high as 10
12 15 or even more well you need to pay
that off before you start investing why
because on average investing returns
eight to ten percent
and you're paying twelve fifteen twenty
percent you gotta get out of debt before
you become an investor
and number three before you become an
investor is you need to become a saver
you need to save that money
because if you don't have money to
invest or a cushion god forbid you don't
want to tap into your investments
so those are three things that you need
to do before you become an investor
so now if you've done those three things
congratulations now
it's time to invest so step one with
investing is you need to sign up you
need to get in the game all right
so you basically need to sign up open up
an account and link your checking
account that's number one number two
you gotta understand are you doing a
401k are you doing an ira
are you doing a roth ira what's your
account going to be
that's number two number three something
called asset
allocation or your asset mix now what
does this mean here's a quick
finance lesson you really got three
options you got cash
you got stocks and you got bonds so cash
you got you're saving that money
now with your asset allocation you got
stocks and you got bonds now what are
stocks what are bonds
stocks are basically shares of a company
and bonds
are basically ious where you're lending
a company money so here's my quick
little advice for you on this if you're
young
if you're in your 20s and your 30s and
you're watching this video you should be
at least
80 percent in stocks 20 bonds
to flip that on the other side if you're
old if you're an 80 year old somehow
watching this video
you should be in 80 bonds 20 stocks so a
lot of times they say
you should have your age in stocks or
bonds
right so you understand that that's your
asset allocation mix
understand that is essential when it
comes to investing so to follow up with
that number four is called risk
tolerance this is all about managing
risk because obviously on one side you
got risk and on the other side you got
reward
so what's your risk tolerance are you
ready to risk it all to put all your
money in or you're saying you know what
i don't want to risk it all but i'm
i'm willing to take some risk or you're
basically saying i don't want to take
any risk
so understand your risk tolerance next
thing moving right along number five
diversification it's basically saying as
they've always said
don't put all your eggs in one basket so
the number here is 500
500 stocks that's the s p 500 it's not
20. it's not 30. it's not 50. it's 100
it's 500 of the largest stocks in the s
p 500 that is diversifying
so if one company does well and one
company doesn't do well and one call
goes up one goes down doesn't matter
you've got 500
that's diversification and number six
you got to just rebalance and track
rebalance and track basically your 80 20
mix or your 2080 mix
are you at 70 30 now you're at 60 40 or
50 50
every year at the end of the year just
rebalance get it back to neutral
and track your performance you don't
need to do this every single day with
passive investing
just track your performance by the end
of the year and last but not least you
need to tune
out the noise there's a lot of opinions
out there
a lot of tv shows a lot of magazines a
lot of newspapers a lot of articles
telling you you got to do this you got
to do that you need to tune
out the noise i don't know if you're a
sports fan but every sunday before the
nfl
they're all picking games all these
sports professionals
ex-nfl players actual professionals
they're picking their teams
and what happens half the time they're
right half the time they're wrong
that's the same thing with stock
investing have to time the right half
the time they're wrong
tune out the noise and just play the
long term game to investing
all right so now it's time for my final
takeaways so check it
when it comes to investing investing
should actually be
boring you want excitement here's what
you should get excited about
get excited about your career get
excited about your job
get excited about your future and the
opportunities that investing
will create down the road that's what
you should get excited about
not investing so back in the day in the
80s and 90s
it was all materialistic and they had
lived by a motto
that was this he who dies with the most
toys wins now what does that mean to you
to me that means
buying a lot of stuff buying a lot of
toys which as we know leads to debt so
now these days there was actually an
article in the washington
post that said this he who dies with the
most toys
now loses i was like oh damn now loses
what does that mean
it means this the new game plan is this
he or she because ladies invest two as
we know
he or she who lives with the
lowest overhead and the highest
flexibility
now wins what does that mean again it's
not about materialism it's not about
things
it's all about experiences and financial
freedom and that's the bottom line now
if you have not seen my video on how to
win the money game
that's right here and also if you have
not seen my video on 10 things
that are killing your wealth that's
right here and if you like what we're
doing here at valuetainment economics go
ahead and subscribe right there and
smash that like button
while you're at it so here's my final
piece of advice
what you do with your money is up to you
but if you're gonna invest hopefully you
follow these three rules
number one you keep it simple number two
you keep your costs low and number three
you stay the course and as always
save that money all we talk is money
all we talk is